einen wunderschönen guten Tag gr dich
Christ K hallo wir sind in put BNE wie
ist die Lage gut also grundsätzlich oder
allgemein im Prinzip im Prinzip okay im
Prinzip ist die Lage ganz cool
eigentlich nee mir geht's gut ja was ist
so eine Grundbedingung für wenn es einem
gut geht bei
dir das mal so ein bisschen chillen kann
also so rein vom Druck her von vom
seelischen Aspekt so dass man sagen kann
okay im Groben und Ganzen stimmt alles
also so wo man sagt klar man jeder
Mensch hat sorgen und es gibt immer
irgendwo Problematiken und denkt ah
jetzt habe ich hier schon wieder ein
bisschen Stress und und da aber solange
das das was das was unterm Strich steht
immer noch sagen kann ne ist okay kriegt
man bewältigt ist alles cool dann geht's
mir gut wie ist das wenn man dann sowas
wie Verliebt in Berlin dreht da ist do
wahrscheinlich mit Chill gar nichts ne
das war anstrengend das war anstrengend
hät gesagt ja die Lage ist nicht so ne
aber das ist ja der Punkt also mir
geht's dann gut wenn ich arbeiten kann
mir geht's dann gut wenn ich das machen
kann was ich liebe wenn ich mich
verwirklichen kann sei es jetzt mal in
der Schauspielerei oder sei in meinen
fotokunstschen ist egal Hauptsache ich
kann ich bin kreativ also was ich am
allermeisten hasse im Leben we da kriege
ich eine Gänse wenn ich dran denke ist
so Stillstand so nichts passiert das ist
glaube ich das ist das Schlimmste und
solange ich weiß die Dinge entwickeln
sich ich tue was passieren Sachen fühle
ich mich wohl so aber WN ich we ich
sitzt nur rum und passiert gar nicht
also selbst wenn ich gar nicht mal das
also die Notwendigkeit bestehen würde
dass ich arbeiten müsste ja ich würde
trotzdem die Krise kriegen also allein
dieser Fakt nur rumzusitzen und zu sagen
oh was mache ich heute gehe ich mal
schwimmen oder gehe ich Basketball
spielen da wür ich die Krätze kriegen so
würdest du sagen professionalität ist
eine
Charaktereigenschaft ich find
professionalität ist auch eine Frage der
Konzentration ja ja also klar nee ist es
eigentlich weil also sag mal so es gibt
verschiedene Aspekte die da da wichtig
sind also klar ein Talent ist eine Sache
Talent ist das was du mitbringst und das
mehr oder weniger auch nachher
entscheidet ob du gut sein kannst oder
nicht professionalität ist eine Sache
von Erfahrung und Konzentration also ist
halt wirklich so bin ich jetzt darauf
konzentriert gebe ich 100% alles oder
mache ich es halt so nebenbei und mal
hier und da und dann bist du halt auch
schnell unprofessionell und wirklich
wirklich wirklich professionell zu sein
ist auch wahnsinnig schwierig also es
ist nicht einfach in in gerade wenn man
viele Dinge macht professionell zu sein
weil ich merke gerade oft so gerade weil
ich viel mache
äh ist die Gefahr oft da dass man sich
verzettelt also verzettelt in dem Fall
dass du sagst so weil ich immer so viel
auf einmal mache macht man eine Sache
z.B da mal ein Fotoshooting ich habe
jetzt ein Fotoshooting gemacht die
Strecke steht die Ausstellung stehen und
so und bin schon wieder beim nächsten
Ding undwoh ich merke so ey hättest du
dich eigentlich vielleicht länger nur
auf dieses eine fotoshootingon
konzentriert und auch die Auswertung
besser wäre vielleicht der Erfolg oder
die oder auch einfach die das was dabei
rausgekommen ist größer also bin ich
immer so e cool habe ich gemacht geil
finde ich cool ma ich nächste so ja und
das ist nich auch wieder ein Nachteil
den ich selber merke weil klar wenn du
sich einhalb Jahre lang nur um ein Ding
kümmerst kann nürlich auch in die Hose
gehen aber dann kann natürlich auch sein
dass du dich so intensiv damit
beschäftigst dass du alle Kanäle nutzen
konntest und mir reicht teilweise dass
ich drei Kanäle genutzt habe von
irgendeem Projekt und dann mache ich das
nächste so weil es mir gar nicht oft um
diesen Erfolg sachee geht s eher um das
ist dass ich es mache also so aber weil
ich verdiene mein Geld als Schauspieler
so das ist mein das ist mein erstes das
ist das ist mein Schlacht was das ist
mein großes Ding so und alles andere ist
für mich ein Spaß alles andere ist für
mich für die Ablenkung für für die
Kreativität so für die Abwechslung im
Leben einfach und das ist mir teilweise
dann egal ob also ich will das Shooting
einfach nur machen und ob es nachher
überhaupt gar keiner sieht ist mir dann
fast wurscht so so sollte es aber
eigentlich nicht sein weil man natürlich
auch was macht und dann auch weitergehen
sollte und da habe ich mich halt oft
selber sag so e Alter du bist jetzt
schon wieder in fünf Dörfern weiter aber
es Bib noch mal also so hier da sind
auch noch ganz viele Baustellen die noch
zu Ende bauen muss so und das ist halt
einer meiner Schwächen so wo ich sage so
durch die FIFA durch die viele
Kreativität renne ich halt auch oft los
so aber
wenn man etwas sehr minuziös macht
besteht da nicht die Gefahr dass die
Leidenschaft flöten geht da fängt's
wieder an mit der Professionalität weil
Leidenschaft ist oft nur ein Starter
Leidenschaft ist ein Motor mm man merkt
ganz oft es ist so wenn du mit jeder
kennt es du bist mit dem Kumpel irgendwo
gesessen oder sit mit Freunden irgendwo
man hat was getrunken und alles sind
lustig und kennst du ploppen die Ideen m
machen geil und das kennt jeder und
keine macht ja ja klar weil Leidenschaft
ist dieses geil das müssen wir machen
Fett und dann hat man es vielleicht noch
eine Woche im Kopf das ist eine geile
Idee und dann setzt dich hin und dann
fängt schon an weiß du oh [__] ey wie
bringe ich den das jetzt auf Papier und
plötzlich kommen die problemeer merkst
du oh dafür bräuchte ich aber ding ding
ding ding ding ding und
Leidenschaft und die Professionalität
entsteht einfach darin das einfach
trotzdem weiterzuführen zu sagen scheiß
drauf scheß ma ich das ist egal okay so
Riesenberg ich scheiß drauf ma ich ja
und das ist wahnsinnig schwierig
deswegen sind kreative Prozesse einfach
also merst ja auch im Film ein Autor
also ein Autor schreibt ein Buch so
seine Vision geiles Ding me oft habe ich
Bücher gelesen so fett coole Nummer
liest dich richtig fett ja und dann
kommen so viele einzelne Sachen dazu so
Gelder Finanzierung Regisseure
Produzenten al so Redakteure und jeder
muss da irgendwie SEAG machtam und am
Ende hast du was mal hat's richtig geil
geklappt und du hast einen fetten Film
gemacht und mal ist halt so
ja aber knallst D nicht manchmal am Set
ja sicher na klar knallt also das sit
schon ist natürlich schöner wenn es
nicht knallt aber manchmal ist es auch
ganz gut weil da dadurch entstehen
Emotionen dadurch entstehen Spannungen
wenn man das dann die das wir die
Aufgabe einesisseurs wenn wenn der weiß
wie er mit Emotion umzugehen hat dann
wollen die ja auch manchmal dass du
richtig angezckt bist sag Alter noch so
ein Ding und ich hau dir eins auf die
Schnauze ja aber genau das will er ja ja
und DAH will er dich auch hintreiben
wenn er dich gut führen kann ganz genau
wie mit sowas umgehen muss ja und wie
deine Energie gerade in die Szene
einfließen lässt aber dann hast du ein
guten Regisseur wenn du einen schlechten
hast dann ja entweder macht er gar
nichts und du stehst halt allein im
freiem Felde und musst da gucken wohin
mit mir jetzt gerade und wohin mit
meiner Emotion Motto biet mir mal was an
biet mir mal was an oder sag gar nichts
oder so ja ja oder oder sagt ständig
irgendwas anderes od sagst du Mann also
eine gerade Linie hast du auch nicht so
weißt du also Führung grundsätzlich ist
eine schwere Sache das merkt man einfach
ich habe ja mit vielen gearbeitet viele
waren gut und bei anderen was Hal auch
okay aber es ist halt so wo sagt okay
man merkt wo liegen die Stärken bei
jemand wo nicht so es gibt Menschen die
sind nicht so gut in der Führung z. mer
okay der ist einfach keine also ein
Führer wie sagt man das
Führungspersönlichkeit zu sein das ist
das heißt noch lange nicht dass man
deswegen schlecht ist aber es ist oft
einfacherst okay da ist jemand der hält
das Team zusammen so ja und manchmal
merke ich okay das jemand extremst
kreativ der hat eigentlich ein geilen
geinen Blick auf Dinge aber ist halt
nicht so kann sich Hal nicht so
durchsetzen weiß und dann merkt man auch
so schade eigentlich weil der wär ein
Top Typ aber da ist fäng kommen wieder
die menschlichen Komponenten und du
arbeitest halt auch gerade als
Schauspieler dein Werkzeug ist Emotion
und Emotion das kennen wir alle ist eine
Sache die nicht so einfach händelbar ist
oder nicht also es ist halt einfach ein
Punkt und ich verstehen halt auch viele
nicht die nicht Schauspieler sind wenn
ich Kameramann bin dann kann ich die
beschissenste Laune der Welt haben aber
völlig scheißegal ich kann mich hinter
die Kamera stellen ich muss m auf meinen
Job konzentrieren ich muss trotzdem gute
Bilder einfangen aber meine persönliche
Meinung mein meine Emotion ist nicht so
wichtig und wird auch nicht gefragt ich
he ich kann meine Arbeit sozusagen als
Schutz vor mich stellen sagen das ist
jetzt mein persönliches Belang und das
ist meine Arbeit auf die konzentriere
ich mich als Schauspieler gibt es nicht
als Schauspieler sind deine Emotionen
das ist das womit du arbeitest natürlich
musst du so professionell sagen sagen
guck mal beis ich habe letztens in
meinem Film habe ich völlig bescheuert
aber es war wirklich so ich habe Scheiße
geträumt ich habe völlig beschissen
geträumt was selten vorkommt aber da ist
echt so war ein von diesen reellen
Träumen wo du dann echt aufwachst und so
ein Hals hast so dann machst du auf und
hast schon so direkt morgens so ein
Brett so es ist also quasi als wä es
passiert ja klar kennt jeder du warst
auf so und gerade diese Träume die so
der Aufwachphase hast und denkst du
alter was für scheiß ey ich hau gleich
jemanden eine weil es echt so richtig
Zorn in dir dann kommst du ein Set wirst
geschminkt und du weißt genau dieser
Zorn ist ja gerade völlig Fehler Platz
weil das was ich gerade spielen muss hat
damit nichts zu tun ja und dann stehst
du da es ist früh morgens
ja so gleich morgens Ding Kaffee okay
lebendig hallo Emotion die me Sitz noch
so da kratzen denken so oh es ist früh
und du musst gich und dann hast du aber
auch noch so ein so ein richtig
Scheißgefühl in dir boah das ist
manchmal echt TFF ist echt TFF und dann
denkst du wie werde ich jetzt diese
Scheiße los wie werde ich jetzt diese
Emotion los ich muss sie ich muss sie
loswerden kann ich meine Szene nicht
spielen und das ist halt oft so das das
kann man nicht verstehen wenn man diesen
Beruf nicht macht dass es wahnsinnig
schwierig ist weil du dich im Endeffekt
vor 80 Leute stellst dein Brustkorb
aufreißt und sagst so Leute ich sch mir
alle mal schön in mein Herz weiß du so
und das ist natürlich umso sicherer du
dich fühlst umso besser dich mit allem
verstehst umso geiler ist das aber wenn
du z.B auch ein tre hast der nicht so
geil läuft da wei kommt gleich einer mit
dem gesalzenen Finger ja und du fühl
sich auch nicht so wohl weil es einfach
alles nicht so harmonisch ist du musst s
aber trotzdem nackt machen ja ja so
seelig ist natürlich wahnsinnig
schwierig also so um das mal versuchen
zu erklären was die Arbeit eigentlich
ausmacht und dann sagen schpiel sind so
Zicken und Diven ja nein das NAT auch
schwierig also so du kannst nicht
einfach sagen so ich ich schütze mich
jetzt und um so schwieriger Schauspieler
sind umso emotionaler und verletzlicher
sind sie eigentlich und oft ist so eine
Überreaktion von Schauspielern einfach
nur ein Schutz so ich muss mich jetzt
schützen weil oder auch auch Angst so
ich mach mich hier auf und alle gucken
mich an und alle können Stückchen von
meinem von meinem von meine von meiner
Seele haben aber ich muss mich irgendwo
auch davor schützen so und das ist halt
oft so ein Ding bei bei Künstlern
allgemein weil sie eigentlich Künstler
eigentlich sehr sehr sensible Menschen
sind und sehr weiche Menschen um soo
härter geben sie sich manchmal im
äußeren weiß du das ist halt oft so ein
WE ist da fotografieren etwas wo man was
du liebst um eben mal so die andere
Seite zu haben definitiv definitiv also
also a hat mich das inszenieren immer
schon sehr Spaß gemacht einfach das das
Kreieren von Dingen also me eigene
Vision zu sein Schauspieler bist du die
Vision eines Autoren eines regisseures
und die musst du versuchen möglichst gut
umzusetzen
in meiner eigenen Arbeit das ist meine
Vision BAM und das ist bin ich da darf
ich da darf auch ich ich sein so und da
darf ich ich sein mit allen meinen
Macken mit allen meinem verrückt sein
und so und das ist toll und das ist
genau das was ich auch brauche im
Gegenzug dazu und da bin ich einfach
hinter der Kamera was sage ich so geil
kann ich einfach mal machen so und muss
mich nicht davorstellen das ist toll
super dann finde ich mit allem noch eine
Menge Erfolg dan und viel Spaß und
Leidenschaft und
Professionalität vielen dan danke dir B
de